[Music]
hey everybody surprise
not really like nobody's surprised to
see us here we are
again swallowed wrong
uh-huh sure no
i don't even know why i said that
what are you talking about
i don't know okay
what am i playing i don't know
we saw prey
which is uh part of the uh predator
franchise
which i i don't know how they worked out
the licensing
they must have got a better deal on this
because if you actually look at the
predator
creature
it's one of the ones from the movie
predators basically yeah remember the
ones that they call them like a
wolf-like one which are the bigger heads
yeah it's like that it's
slender
but it's one of those
and because it's not like one of the
ones from predator one or two so because
it's one of those maybe they got a deal
on the franchise i don't know maybe for
the license plate didn't cause as much
to use that one
but it's still a good movie
this was surprisingly awesome i liked it
i liked it a lot yeah um
taking place with comanche warriors here
in the united states in the 1700s
the comanches fight the [ __ ] thing
got a girl with them
and uh she's not so much of a merry suit
where i'm like ah come on you know but
she she does a pretty good job and then
they run into a bunch of french fur
trappers that do [ __ ] too
it's pretty cool it's pretty cool and
and um
the french all speak french through the
whole thing and they don't translate it
they have
if you put turn the subtitles on
there'll be captions but the captions
are in french too
i told them what a couple of the words
meant because i but i can make i took
french for like four years but i've
forgotten a lot of it but i knew some of
what they were saying
when they saw the when they saw the
indie one and then the one like swear
word i'm like i'm pretty sure that means
bastard yeah
[Laughter]
and he looked it up and he's like yep
you're right yeah he's bastard i was
like i can't believe i remembered that
um
pretty straightforward uh i liked it
because it's happening in nature
so that's kind of true to the original
predator one i don't like it when it's
kind of in a city
even though
avp one and two were good
avp1 was kind of like uh something out
of in the mountains of madness where
it's taking place in an in a forgotten
alien temple on our and our antarctica
and they fight the aliens too the
xenomorphs that's good
and then avp2 was like in a suburban
environment but it was still good it was
about a a predator
who is basically a game warden and he's
trying to stop the xeno [ __ ] outbreak
it's pretty good
this one is also in nature
so it kind of adds to the original to
that tone that the original one had
i do have some problems with the movie
but not a lot of it didn't a lot of my
problems with it don't have much to do
with the movie i think the advertising
campaign did this movie a [ __ ]
disservice all right
the advertising campaign [ __ ]
stressed [ __ ] a bunch of
[ __ ] you know what i mean
uh you know culture
kind of you know what do you call it
they made the movie seem like it was
going to be some kind of triumph of
feminism or something it really didn't
have anything to do with that it had
it's just that's just the [ __ ] line
that they did i think it turned a lot of
people off a lot of guys are teenage
guys they don't hear that [ __ ]
they don't want to hear but they won't
hear about that [ __ ] yeah they won't
hear about that [ __ ] the girls are
terrible they want badass movie you know
well it was pretty badass this is about
us
so as i was saying i don't think the i
think they did the movie a disservice
with it with a stupid advertising
campaign that was unnecessary i didn't
see any of that so yeah that was yeah i
don't think they i don't i don't really
watch trailers or yeah it's not [ __ ]
not usually uh well it's not so much the
trailers it was the articles that the
online
uh
movie what they were saying about it and
they were they're paid to say things
about movies to make hype
and
they pay him to see the stupidest [ __ ]
start to turn off the core customers but
no [ __ ] it's good it's a good
predator movie the i think the best
thing about this one and i kind of wish
that more long-running horror and action
and sci-fi franchises would do this
would
is that it just went back to basics it
went back to what was good about the
first movie right because i kind of feel
like we've talked about this multiple
times horror franchises sci-fi
franchises the longer they go on yeah
they tend to like over explain things
they expand the mythology out to a point
where no one gives a [ __ ] and he's
talking about terminator where no i'm
talking about a lot of different yeah a
lot of them i mean
so it's just kind of like i said it's a
lot better when everything is just i
mean the first predator movie everybody
loves the first predator movie i can't
think of a single person on earth who
doesn't like the first master predator
movie it's a it's amazing
what was so great about that one it was
this simple it's simple it's just like a
bunch of people in the woods they're
fighting this horrible monster they
don't know what it is and it's just you
feel for the people you're scared for
them like the monster is scary and it's
just like a big like action it's just
really good although although i want to
kind of i want to kind of correct that a
little bit it's simple on the surface
it actually has a lot of depth into it
and i don't mean simple as like i don't
mean that as a derogatory term and
actually that's i think that's laudatory
in this type of thing
i think the problem with a lot of
sequels like the the further into a
franchise you go is people tend to like
over complicate
but you know a lot of times by necessity
because they're like well we're trying
to show you something new or trying to
expand something out so i kind of feel
like they again like over explain things
or they go off in a bunch of different
directions so i think it was actually
kind of a brilliant idea
to take predator which like i said i
didn't hate like a lot of the sequels
but a lot of them weren't really all
that good or all that memorable but it
just went right back to but it went back
in time it went back to when the
predators i mean it's three four hundred
years in the past so even the predators
didn't have the technology that they had
in the ages movie you know they look
different they didn't have like the
plasma cannons and all that other kind
of stuff so they still had cooler
weapons than us but they weren't as uh
technologically advanced as they were in
the 80s or maybe maybe they did have
that technology so that that wasn't in
the rules then because a lot of times
you know i mean hunting styles and rules
and everything would change over
centuries so they were using more
primitive weapons but those might have
been
very primitive weapons for the for the
for for the yeah well the cool thing and
they kind of i don't they didn't like
obviously like spell this out but
obviously one of the cool things about
the predator is because they're hunters
but they have a code of honor so it's
just kind of like they're not gonna like
just go hunt people that are in a trap
or something like that and they kind of
go into that a little bit in this movie
too and they're gonna kind of to an
extent i mean obviously they have heat
vision which is kind of cheating but
it's like um that was normal for them
that's what i mean that was normal for
them so they're gonna use the same kind
of [ __ ] that you use it's you know and i
i was reading like a comment about it
and they said the cool thing about this
is that if you notice the predator
actually doesn't use
like uh projectile style weapons until
the comanches start using them against
him and then he's like oh okay well all
bets are off i'm gonna use my [ __ ] now
too and it's it's it's not really
so i've heard people say that it's like
a sense of honor but having a background
in in this in hunting it's not honor per
se it's being sporting
is what it is yeah it's no sport if you
have too much of a technological
uh um
supremacy over over the prey yeah like i
said it's kind of interesting there's
different kinds of hunting some hunting
is just for food you're going directly
just for food other hunting is more
sport-like
like there's a difference between
trying to just put meat on the table
that's just business you know that's
using firearms
but if you're in the more sporting
seasons you know what i mean like i've
done all this to
[ __ ] uh primitive weapons like bows i
can hunt with a bow i got my comp my
compound bows down in the garage but
it's so old i'll bring that [ __ ] up one
of these days and uh muzzleloaders a lot
of stuff i did was with muzzle loaders
which
you got one shot that's it
you know chances have you been able to
reload in front of a deer nah [ __ ] is
going to run
so it has to be a single well placed
shot
and the range is close
so that's what that's what a lot that's
what a lot of non-hunters get to get
wrong about the the predator series it
it seems like honor probably from your
point of view but it's more about the
sporting mentality well that's what i
meant i was just using that word like as
a as a shortcut
i just wanted to touch that up because
it's not just you everybody else does
that too no it's about about being
sporting yeah yeah that's what i meant
that's right and i think most people
that use that terminology maybe that's
not the correct terminology but that's
what they mean yeah that's what they
mean that's what they mean but so i
really like that and honestly
it kind of like plays into the whole
because you know if you hadn't seen the
film and you were just going on it's
like oh you know how is some like skinny
little girl gonna like fight against the
predator but the thing about it is that
for a long chunk of the film the
predator doesn't really like attack her
because he doesn't think that she's a
threat because at the beginning she's
really not a threat yeah and to be
honest like as it goes on and she kind
of like she doesn't really have to use
she doesn't use force against him she
actually uses her other like her kind of
guile and wit and like her tracking and
trapping and stuff like that more of a
cat and mouse thing rather than like
fighting him hand-to-hand and in the end
she does
beat him
there is a an element of luck in it
though too there's some luck with the
firearm which that's just the way it was
she did win um what i liked about it is
that basically all the men were
kind of shown as kind of how they were
the comanche braves were young
which i liked the fact that they showed
them young most those guys
once they got to a certain age they
weren't going out and doing all that
[ __ ]
you know which they showed that the
older guys were back at camp supervising
the younger guys to make sure they were
coming up through the ranks so most of
the comanches they were fighting were
20s and 30s young guys
they were right
that's what they would be actually the
guy that played the brother tabi i think
this is his first movie yeah
and uh they were just
bravely fighting something that they
could not comprehend they thought it was
a monster
from their legends like their version of
a boogie man yeah they because they
didn't have a concept of aliens they had
no idea that when when she sees the ship
at the beginning she says thunderbirds
the thunderbird right
and which is what they would have said
yeah she said i thought a thunderbird
and then it shows up
and it's it's half invisible and it's
doing [ __ ] she saw it killing other
animals it was hunting bear and it was
hunting uh yeah
oscar said uh prey was awesome that
grizzly bear fight might be the best
yeah in any predator that was pretty
awesome you can watch it free on hulu
they're streaming now if you're in the
us if you're overseas like uk i think
it's on disney plus yeah this should
have got a theatrical release though i
think it did didn't it no it didn't i
think a lot of people were complaining
about that because it's i guess they
decided maybe they thought it wouldn't
be worth it or more people wouldn't go
see it but this was like way better than
the predator and that got us like a
theatrical release yeah the predator i
didn't think it was that good it wasn't
and that's the thing the good things
the predator
jane black's one
i'm so frustrated at that movie because
it had some really good elements that
were spoiled by the other elements so
that movie kind of fought against itself
some of that [ __ ] needed to be edited
out i just thought it was
like the [ __ ] the iron man suit at
the end what what are you [ __ ] you
talking about oh honestly i don't even
remember like yeah and then they kind of
i remember it being like okay when we
because i think we saw it at the theater
but and then they come up with this idea
like well what it is is they're coming
here because of global warming and they
need dna and they're modifying
themselves with our dna no you don't
need that man no why did you talk about
that
don't over complicate the [ __ ] leave
mystery to the god on the goddamn
predator
leave it alone
when you know too much it's not [ __ ]
scary anymore leave it the [ __ ] alone
that's what happened with predator with
terminator
well like i said that's what i liked
about this one that's why i think this
movie was such like a genius thing
because they're like we're going way
back in time to 1719 yeah um which is
and we don't know if the predators have
been here before or if it's like the
first time they've been here or whatever
um
but we're seeing like a a slightly more
primitive predator like fighting
people that didn't have guns really or
you know any kind of like technology or
or even like any concept of what the
[ __ ] this thing was i did actually
really like the scene when
the when all the um
the comanche guys when they actually
first saw the thing because for a long
time she was like hey i think there's
like some weird [ __ ] out there that's
not a bear and they didn't really
believe her at first but then when they
finally see it yeah they just like
jumped right in there and started
fighting it because to them it's just
like well it's just a monster
and we need to get rid of it like they
didn't like just you know piss their
pants and run away they're just like
well
we'd better jump in there and kill it
and then later on they run into the
french fur trappers they were bad asses
too and hateful [ __ ] not all of
them but a lot of them
i think they were even discussing raping
that girl uh but they ended up using her
and the other one is bait remember yeah
and they they knew something was
haunting them and they knew it was
invisible they didn't quite know what it
was but they were using guns against it
they all got [ __ ] killed and then um
if you've seen predator 2 i believe the
pistol from predator 2 that was given to
danny glover as a as a as a trophy i
think that's the same pistol danny
rowling said that like a way of thinking
it was like an easter egg yet is that it
okay yeah because uh that it shows where
that pistol came from
all right now
the when the movie ends the girl still
has it as far as i'm concerned so i
don't think so there's we don't know the
story of how the predators got the damn
pistol
because at the end of the movie she
still had it but like i said there's
like a 300 400 year gap in there so it's
like they had plenty of time if you had
to go in there get it yeah so it must
appear later
in the hands of the predators maybe when
they kill her that might happen later i
don't know or after she dies
and somebody else gets it and then they
get killed or something like that like i
said 300 400 it was just a french
french [ __ ]
flintlock style muzzle loading combat
pistol
which they which what i did like about
the movie is that modern thinking is is
that you carry a pistol and then you
carry it like a rifle
that's not the way it was in the 1700s
and even the 1600s they carried six
pistols
and [ __ ] two rifles well you probably
might have had two because you weren't
there there was no time to reload
things everywhere yeah and they were all
tied together on level straps you'd have
a rifle slung over your back and then
one of them in your hand
so you had two rifle shots and a whole
bunch of six
you know pistol shots and then you might
be with a group of ten dudes that were
all
loaded up like that you know so you had
firepower just you had to carry a lot of
[ __ ] iron with you
yeah
it wasn't until the revolver that [ __ ]
started to become kind of practical well
and i kind of liked the scene too where
like the french guy got like his leg
blown off and then she was trying to
help him because she had she could was a
healer and stuff and so he was showing
her how to use
the gun
and you could see like by the look at
her face she was just kind of like this
seems like a really lot of trouble
which kind of goes back to what i said
before and this is historically accurate
native americans had no interest in
pistols or rifles or firearms there was
no advantage to them well not in that
until the metallic cartridge case
as soon as you can have a metallic
cartridge cage was a fully enclosed what
you would call a bullet or a round and
you could put it that was practical
because it could get rained on you could
carry it and it was reliable indians
didn't give a [ __ ] about
muzzle loading flintlock and even
percussion cap weapons they might use
them to kill buffalo every now and then
because you're not under stress of
combat but for combat the way to go is a
bow
or a [ __ ] war club
or what they would call a tomahawk
which wasn't an indian weapon it was a
french weapon the french trappers were
selling to the indians and then they
could make their own too it was actually
the front sauce as as it was known in
the in europe a french battle axe that
was a good weapon well and uh nauru the
main character in that she has one of
those yeah and she also has like a thing
well she like braids this big long thing
like ties around so she can like use it
as throwing weapon and you pull it back
i think hers was made out of stone
though i don't think it was metal was it
well i couldn't i think it was metal i
couldn't really tell it looked like it
was metal but i couldn't really tell
yeah
they tried really hard i mean the
producer on this movie was um
comanche nation and blackfeet nation so
they really did try to make this as
historically accurate as possible and
matter of fact on hulu there is a
version of this movie they did a whole
they did a whole version in all comanche
yeah that's what i wanted to see because
that was my gripe yeah i was saying i
wish this was just an all comanche it is
there there is a version okay i want to
see that one they made they made two
alternate versions uh with two alternate
audio tracks yes you can watch it in all
comanche or you can watch it like i want
to see you all come at you because the
version we watched was english was
mostly english but it had mixed in some
comanche and like like i said mixed in
french that wasn't translated oh man
that's great i want to see that that's
on hulu yeah okay yeah both versions are
on we're gonna see that like the uh the
the audio track is on there yeah and all
in all comanche would have been more
kind of like apocalypto
a bit real immersive like apocalypto
yeah i want i want to see that one
tonight well because i mean they thought
about it because they were like well we
could do it like we could start out in
comanche and then go to english kind of
like the hunt for red october which
started out in russian and then went to
english but they said we tried to do it
it didn't really work so we decided just
to do like mix in some comanche with the
english but then do an all comanche
version in case you want to watch it
like that so
from what i've heard of like the people
that have watched both versions they
like the comanche version a lot better
so
i mean yeah i i would actually if i'd
known that before i watched it i would
have watched that one
more than well we'll always see that one
next yeah uh hugo said i watched the
comanche version i liked it yeah that's
what i'm saying it's just kind of like i
was gonna complain about that now i
can't complain about it now you can't
complain about it because they they have
already like thought about your concerns
because i was thinking man if that [ __ ]
was was all
in comanche it would have been kind of
like apocalypto yeah
well there is a version like that okay
i'm gonna get this so like i said they
thought about it i'm gonna get it on
blu-ray yeah see and that is kind of
like the highest compliment because tom
will usually only buy movies he releases
i really really like it i thought like i
said it's
i just really like that it went back to
the essence of predator and just made it
it didn't over complicate anything it
just had a very very simple
story it was mostly about naru and her
like awesome hero dog who and the dog
and tammy points out the dog doesn't die
i was worried about the dog a few times
but the dog is like such a great
character too
and she's basically just trying to like
prove herself as a warrior because
nobody in her and this is very true to
the comanche like kind of uh you know
gender divide at the time it's just kind
of like you know women weren't warriors
you weren't hunters you kind of stayed
you were healers and blah blah and but
she wanted to be a warrior nobody really
thought she could do it and the thing
about it is like the first half three
quarters of the movie she [ __ ] it up
yeah so it's not like she just comes out
and oh i'm awesome at everything uh she
screws up a lot of things yeah she's
going through kind of like a tribal
right right to do this it's kind of like
a comanche version of ranger school yeah
and i mean she eventually makes it but
everybody else gets wiped out what i did
like about it too is that the just in in
good predator tradition they showed some
new equipment it's mask it looks like
it's bumped like a bone mask yeah it's
got some it's got the three laser beams
but each one controls a separate dart
they can fire out uh which it was a
projectile weapon but a primitive one it
was shooting guided darts
uh and then it he also had a
a collapsible shield that would come out
like that it looked like it was made out
of some kind of bone it was pretty neat
it was sharp around the edge too wasn't
it when you cutting stuff with it
i don't know if that was the mask or he
had like something else well
his shield yeah yeah yeah the shield was
yeah and i think it was sharp around it
was yeah because he was cutting stuff
with it and he kind of like went like
into a tree yeah yeah like that i got to
see it again a lot of stuff happened so
fast i wasn't able to absorb it all yeah
and i said yeah it was just like i said
it's just a really simple it just went
way back to basics yeah and just had
like a just a straightforward
action horror thriller that also had
like a lot of really good
characterization like i said you really
liked naru's character you really liked
her conflict with her brother they
didn't overdo the characterization i
think they they struck like a really
good balance between
giving you enough characterization that
you cared about what happened to them
but not so much that you were kind of
like yeah let's get on with like the
predator like killing people you know
what i mean i think they struck like a
good balance and it's not too long it's
only like an hour and a half or hour and
40 minutes something like that so it's
really kind of lean and mean yeah i
gotta see it again a couple more times i
want to see the comanche version um but
i'm gonna say like with predator one
the the the apparent simplicity actually
hides a lot of
mythic
depth to it like a good example would be
kind of like uh
dylan and mac
uh
going after the predator for two
different reasons
mack is trying to avenge his buddy who
was killed and they were the sole
survivors of their unit back in
back in special forces
and he's trying to
avenge his buddy's death he's willing to
give his life to do it and then you have
uh dylan and dylan is trying to
basically kind of in a certain way a
tone
and to prove to the universe that even
though he's a cia agent who's
lying and twisting and cheating to get
the job done
that doesn't mean he's not an honorable
warrior he's actually
with he's trying to avenge the death of
all his the team who got slaughtered
before them and all the guys that are
dying on this mission even if it kills
him so there's just there there was a
lot of depth there
but you have to put yourself in the
shoes of these characters of why they're
doing this well and they didn't belabor
it no they didn't
figure it out that's what i mean and i
think that's like a hallmark of good
writing right and i think that that's
kind of why people like the original
predator so much and why this one's
getting a lot of praise too is that
there's a lot of like character depth
but they don't have to like go on and on
with exposition you figure a lot of it
out like on your own that's why i got to
see it again i got to see it again to uh
get over the initial spectacle and start
analyzing the story a little bit better
usually it takes repeated viewings to to
pick up on a lot and yeah it's i mean if
i see a movie that i really really like
i mean i usually will always like want
to watch it again for me it was a lot
easier to understand predator one
because i can't i was in the service
just a few years after that movie came
out so it was the same culture
even though there's contractors that
those guys are playing contractors that
have been out of service a lot of the
[ __ ] that they wore and did was the same
[ __ ] we did
so i know what they were thinking
these guys are from old cultures so it's
gonna take it's gonna take me a while to
kind of adjust make the adjustment
of what it is they're thinking about
the french were interesting
i got to go back and analyze the french
again
and try to pick up everything that
they're saying
i meant to mention if you didn't know
that this was directed by dan
trachtenberg who did 10 cloverfield lane
which is actually a pretty uh good movie
he also
did an episode of black mirror okay uh
play test and the premiere episode of
the
very well-regarded amazon series the
boys so
no it's not he's that you know it's not
pray 2021 it's pray 2022 man it's only
on hulu
if you're in the us everywhere else i
think it's disney plus
like i said i don't like hulu is eight
dollars and four cents a month that's
how much i pay for it you might be able
to stream it off of hulu though huh a
single v a la carte
i don't think hulu works like that what
about amazon amazon might have streaming
no no because it's a hulu exclusive
okay it might like it might widen out
later i'm not really sure like how the
streaming services work because
sometimes like i'll see movies that for
example like is a shutter exclusive but
then like after a while it'll show up on
like other streaming services so i think
there's like a contract where
for x months
x amount of months like you can have
like
the only streaming rights to it and then
it will go out to the wider thing but
because
yeah so because this was
i think hulu is u.s only far as i'm
aware
so
what i know like whoever has doesn't
have hulu like i think that you can
watch it on disney plus though because i
think that the
studio that made this
is owned by disney and i think hulu
might be owned by disney
so if i'm not missing somebody in there
said that well the predator should be
able to kill all these guys easily
should have just annihilated
you don't understand hunting well then
there's no conflict there either if that
could just happen if a predator could
just come to earth and go but you yeah
you know you don't understand hunting
they had the technology probably to drop
a bio weapon to kill everything on the
planet if they wanted to that's not the
point of sport hunting they wanted the
challenge yeah they're using primitive
weapons from their point of view against
superior odds
all right in this case
see he didn't use anything other than
bladed weapons and some darts he was
using the same [ __ ] they were using and
he was over he was outnumbered also
because there was a bunch of them and
there was only one event right and their
saver in the hunt and he's taking
trophies from it
okay it's not about combat and stacking
up
you know hundreds of [ __ ] enemies and
[ __ ] that's not what it's about they're
saver in the hunt and is something like
this plausible
yeah
yeah
you'll have some people in science
saying oh no you know anything space
faring wouldn't have any needs and it
wouldn't you know be violent it would be
it would have the same values as us it
would be you know even the same
political view no no you're you're
projecting you have something that's
[ __ ] come up through darwinian
[ __ ] evolution and it's very possible
very likely that whatever come up
through there would actually be pretty
mean pretty savage yeah i'd have [ __ ]
space travel and [ __ ]
but it was still like to eat things and
kill things that's plausible
you know and again it's a big universe a
big universe right and the thing is it
doesn't see you as a person it sees you
as an animal
you know i mean an inferior animal like
the same way i look at a frog
okay well and i kind of like that they
established too that the predator wasn't
just fighting against the humans in this
one he was what he fought like animals
uh and a bear yeah and [ __ ] like that so
it's almost kind of like he came there
and he's trying to like figure out well
like who's like the top who's the
biggest challenge yeah yeah and you know
you might say oh that's not scientific
well [ __ ] you go in there and look at
this things [ __ ] hormonal profiles
and it synapses and it's in it in its
[ __ ] nervous system and this thing
might be very kind of like
almost damn erotically aroused by the
[ __ ] fighting killing and eating
you know or may and making trophies that
might be part of its [ __ ] nervous
system
or what if this is a [ __ ] alien
species where this is just a subculture
of them these are the rednecks of the
aliens they're not making these ships
they're buying them
you know other ones of them are doing
other things yeah you don't know if
there's other like yeah
right like you said these might be like
the
the hillbillies of women yeah rednecks
do not
rednecks do not mass-produce
four-wheelers but they buy them
okay they do not mass-produce [ __ ]
trucks but they buy them okay
so
and they go out and [ __ ] kill [ __ ]
and eat it
so it's just the same thing danny
rowling said the look of the predator in
this film was very indian looking all
the way to his mask his mask in this
looked like a wendigo like they were
playing on that troop it might have been
like i said i really did like that they
made the predator also look
like it was three or four hundred years
in the past like he didn't maybe have
either he didn't have like access to the
cool [ __ ] that he had in the later one
or he just chose not to use it because
he knew that the uh you know prey that
he was fighting against wouldn't have it
looking at its head it's it's not the
one from predator one and two it's one
of the ones from
the uh the movie predators
the ones that were hunting the other
predators they kind of had a round head
with a bunch of tent you know with the
jaws that were kind of
longer
round looking
yeah his head was a little narrower yeah
it's narrower than that other one off
that movie
looking the one you don't [ __ ] with said
that i forgot what his name was i'm the
one you don't [ __ ] with the fish burn
character he said that they were kind of
like wolves
hunting the other ones it was a
some kind of beef that they had back
going way back it was one of the other
ones but he was taller and thinner but
you know there's going to be variation
between them all they probably don't
look alike you know well yeah i mean
that would be that would be weird if
they all looked exactly the same yeah
and i think that the guy playing the
predator in this one is this is i don't
know if it's his first movie role but
it's for sure the first time he's played
played a predator i think he's like well
he used to be a basketball player so
he's like until he's tall he's like six
foot seven or something like that
also i want to say to you like when we
watch this movie the woman that is that
plays the main character naru whose name
is uh amber mid thunder
um
i was like god damn she looks so
familiar and so i went she's been in a
bunch of [ __ ] like movies and tv and
stuff i recognized her from
hell or high water
that too yeah we did we watched it
together which was that was a 2016 like
crime movie you'd remember if you saw it
again but she had like a small role in
that so that's where i was recognizing
her from she's been like a ton of stuff
but that's because i was like i know
i've seen her before where the [ __ ] is
it and it was bugging me and that's
where it was
but like i said i really like that they
really tried to
make this as period accurate as possible
i mean obviously it's not period
accurate with the like of an alien
coming to the planet like fighting
everybody but within reason you know
what i mean also i kind of like i like
that they had all native american actors
playing the actual native american
characters that's like really nice to
see
they're not all comanche obviously uh
you know amber mid thunder is sue i
believe but you know danny says it sucks
it didn't show the bomb scene when they
all died being mesmerized but i
remembered i remember they did show that
it came up and some things came up out
of the damn
bomb on his arm were spinning
then then they blew up
well he left it there like on the ground
and they all went up to like i think the
french guys like went up to it like i
wonder what that thing that's right he
didn't kill himself did he
no he left it there on the ground he
left it there on the ground and then
like i think it was all the french guys
that went up to and said that i was like
yeah i was like might might want to back
off a little bit yeah
they didn't know
it's like they never was making noise
they never seen anything like that
before so it's just kind of like you
know it's easy for us now to say it's
like because we've seen all these kinds
of movies well it's like it's like the
comanche yeah they knew that it was
invisible but to them this is just a
boogeyman
yeah and they just no concept they just
approached it
you know as such they were just kind of
like like you said they didn't have any
concept in alien they just thought well
this is a something that shouldn't be
here this is some kind of supernatural
monster yeah and we need to like take it
out yeah like it's a spirit
yeah because it was good it was clear
they could see through it but they could
see it too it's
it's cloak wasn't perfect when it did
certain things you could kind of
you could
remember that yeah and they would hit it
with stuff he would become visible in
certain parts it was well i think she
saw it at first and it actually like
what was a great scene when it was
fighting the bear yeah it got blood on
like it it held the bear up and then the
blood came down and that was the first
time she actually saw it like in its
whole because she had been kind of
tracking it because she kept seeing its
footprints and like other things that it
left and she's like i'm pretty sure this
is not like an animal that we've usually
seen around here but i don't know what
the [ __ ] it is but you know what i mean
so she didn't see it uh you know until
that point john smith said i like that
the french trappers all spoke a slightly
archaic form of french oh good yeah see
like i said they really did try i mean
and i admire that i admire that they
tried to make everything as period
accurate as possible in the context of
obviously like a sci-fi horror movie
about killer hunter aliens
but it's nice that they actually try to
get all the details gotta see it again
because the alien survived the predator
survived didn't he no no she killed him
at the end yeah but there's other ones i
mean he was only how did the predators
end up with that pistol that she had
we don't know yet because she had her
like i said we don't know she had it at
the end from what i remember did you
right but
you know like i said there's 300 400
years and she shot the thing a couple
times and it didn't go off so i don't
know how it went off on
that one time which i think was like
kind of funny because like i said that
was kind of like it was almost like the
payoff of the joke because when the
french guy without the leg yeah showing
her how it worked she didn't say
anything but you could tell by the look
on her face she's like this is really
not this is not good
he used a bunch of vagaries if you know
how to use muzzle loading [ __ ]
firearms he's like well
put enough in there but not too much and
she's probably like
what does that mean
[Laughter]
put the ball in the patch in together
and it was very vague and i know how to
use muzzle loading firearms flint locks
also with [ __ ] frisons and [ __ ]
flash pads and all that [ __ ] and uh to
get that it's a lot more complicated
that you think you got to get that
[ __ ] flint just the right shape so
when it hits the frison it [ __ ] makes
sparks and that's a that's a skill in
itself to get that angle right
and um
you have to [ __ ] prime the flat flash
pad and everything
and you gotta [ __ ] do it a lot before
you can really get it down and
i don't think he could have taught her
how to do it just by telling well she
tried to like use it a bunch of times
and it didn't work yeah you couldn't do
it you know what i mean so you have to
do it so that was a little bit more
realistic i think it's not like she just
like figured it out immediately yeah it
was she was just kind of like [ __ ] and
she was like oh [ __ ] man percussion cap
muzzle loader's far easier than
flintlock and the worst being matchlock
which i never even bothered [ __ ]
[ __ ] with that
because now you got to burn a [ __ ]
wick the whole time
and then you have to make the wick
you can buy it but they made them and i
don't know i mean i could totally
understand if you had if you were really
really good at using bows and arrows and
clubs and stuff like that um and then
somebody shows up it's like hey i've got
this gun which maybe sort of like works
most of the time but takes like a really
really long time to like really it's
like you can shoot one time and then
you're like hang on yeah
you know be like [ __ ] that that's good
that's way too much trouble they in
general weren't any good in the new
world and that's what i'm saying that's
way too much they wouldn't last they
didn't last but i mean if you if you
were [ __ ] hot with the bow and arrow you
just like
yeah it was way better and it was silent
the target wasn't silent you got hit he
started screaming like bloody bird
and and one arrow doesn't kill you you
gotta get hit several times and you
bleed out so they didn't have good
stopping power but they were mostly
using clubs and tomahawks and
hands you know they were [ __ ]
hands-on fighters
knives
and they show a lot of that in this yeah
it's just kind of a lot of the a lot of
the guys like tombe and some of the
other ones like actually fight the
predator like handy by hand-hand yeah
yeah well in those days it made a lot
more sense because it was a lot that's a
lot more rapid fire and really you don't
have to kill somebody all i do is cut
him so bad chances are he wouldn't make
it he might die a couple days later
just blood loss infection
if the guy doesn't have an ability to
[ __ ] do stitches and doesn't have the
ability to [ __ ]
sanitize something he'd die of infection
usually
so you just have to wound somebody bad
that's it and it becomes dead weight
anyway yeah i mean you know that french
guy wasn't like no he wouldn't go
nowhere because he got he got the bottom
part of his leg blown off yeah the dude
with the leg missing he was he's the
goner
well he did die spoiler but yeah that's
uh he wouldn't have made it no he
wouldn't have no i mean she tried to
help him out but you know he died he
probably would have died anyway yeah um
let's wait danny rowling said uh the
predator's crew members will definitely
pay her a visit and retrieve his gear
more than likely
yeah maybe
i heard that they were throwing around i
don't know if they'll ever do this but
that they kind of liked the idea of
you know casting the predator back in
time which like i said i think was like
a brilliant concept that they're
thinking about i don't know if they'll
ever do this but they're thinking about
doing another one where the predator
visits like feudal japan that'd be great
which it would actually be quite awesome
i think that would be pretty awesome and
actually like i was watching some other
reviews of the movie today and people
were like [ __ ] yeah man like send the
predators back like have them fight
dinosaurs and nazis and like whatever
the [ __ ] he's like that'd be super fun
i'd like to see him fight knights or
vikings right exactly
predator versus vikings yeah
i mean the yeah that's the one they
should okay they should make a feudal
japan one and then they should make a
viking one yeah i would watch that not
gonna lie
what about fighting romans roman legions
that too that'd be good too see that
like the possibilities are endless yeah
and you don't really need it just has to
be like a straightforward
monster movie which like i said was kind
of what the first one was romans had
concepts of aliens they knew about that
they would they would be able to figure
that out
because they were writers thinking that
said that stars may be other maybe other
sons and around them might be other
planets and other people
so they would could probably grasp that
and that might be like a really good
scene like a bunch of people like in the
roman senate like talking about i think
this is like foreign
yeah
that'd be like super cool yeah it'd have
some it'd be like
something like spartacus meets uh meets
predator there could be some scientists
in there going this could only be
creatures from men from other planets
they could only think of these i agree
we would know about it if they'd all be
standing there and their tokens looking
oh yeah yeah yeah that's what they would
say fourth throw down says predator
versus seagal
[Laughter]
yeah oh man are we going down that
rabbit hole again
somebody i'm amazed that nobody has done
like uh like a fan edit film of that
like and uploaded it to youtube because
how [ __ ] funny would that be how
funny would that be if you could take
like just all the best [ __ ] from like
the predator movies and edit in steven
seagal like like sitting in a chair like
squinting at the predator
ridiculous somebody do that that would
be funny maybe i'll do it it would take
a long time but it's like i kind of want
to see that now
and justice for me said there was a
predator youtube short film like a fan
film that took place during the crusades
yeah worth your time i think i saw i
think it was only 15 minutes yeah
predator dark age yeah i'm sure there's
been like some fan films and actually i
was watching oliver harper did a review
of of this of prey and he said that this
actually gave off a little bit of fan
film energy and he's like and i don't
mean that in a bad way i mean that it's
like you know this seems like something
that was made by somebody with a lot of
love for the franchise that wanted to
kind of like recapture the spirit of the
original film
um and kind of like strip it back down
to basics which like i said i think was
absolutely the right thing i wonder why
no theatrical release
a lot of people have been complaining
about that because people were like man
this would have been because the
cinematography in this is gorgeous like
where they shot it they shot it in
alberta
and canada uh you know it's supposed to
be the great plains or whatever but um i
mean some of the wide shots and stuff
like that are beautiful and this would
have looked really good on the big
screen i feel like so i don't really
know like i said way shittier movies
than this get a theatrical release and
it's kind of sad that this one didn't
maybe uh they just couldn't afford it
maybe it's like
i don't know what the budget is
a lot of movies are i know but well
that's probably what they thought they
were just kind of like well every
[ __ ] is just like sitting around
on their couch like watching movies at
home nowadays so it's like might as well
like don't even bother with the
theatrical money right because it's be
too expensive yeah i don't like i said i
don't know how much this one cost i
don't think it was all that expensive i
mean it looks good though like some
people have complained about like oh the
cgi of the animals because if you see
like that there's like a scene with like
a like a line like a mountain lion yeah
this is perfect um it's not perfect but
cgi of living animals is never good it's
never yeah perfect and it always like
looks a little bit uncanny the best is
still jurassic park the first one from
1993 guys yeah those actually look like
real animals yeah but the thing well
that wasn't all cgi they had puppets and
stuff too but they they incorporated
both things but to be honest with you if
you're going to have entire
animals that are cgi like an entire bear
or something like that i've seen way
worse than this i mean this
looks pretty [ __ ] gets the job done
it looks pretty [ __ ] it doesn't pull
you out of the movie yeah
i didn't think it did like you could
tell that it was a cgi animal but it
wasn't like super super obvious like so
much so that you're like oh god that
looks like a [ __ ] cartoon animal it
didn't look like that it you could tell
it wasn't real but it didn't really look
i didn't think it looked that bad
um
john smith uh wait a minute yeah planet
of the apes did okay uh cgi did
yeah that's true but like i said anytime
you're doing a person or an animal
it's still even in 2022 it still never
looks quite right yeah and i don't know
if they'll ever get it quite right of
otson just showed up says i just got
here i guess you guys liked the movie
yeah we liked it i give it two thumbs up
it's good
good movie it is very good good yeah it
is very good and check this out khan
there's a full
comanche version where there's no
english at all just comanche in french i
didn't know i'm gonna go back and see
that i didn't know either until after we
watched it and then i was like well [ __ ]
we should have watched that but both
versions are up on on hulu i want to see
the comanche version hulu or disney plus
if you're not if you're not here
yeah and i was saying that man if it was
in comanche it would be like apocalypto
yeah but it's got both versions up there
i want to see which is cool because then
like if people are like i don't want to
read subtitles blah blah blah so like
then they can watch the english language
version but
you know for those of us who don't care
about reading subject well i put
subtitles on even if the movie's in
english yeah because they can't [ __ ]
hear he didn't know that because he's
down in tijuana he bootlegged the [ __ ]
he boo
uh but no you want to i'm going to get
the i want to see the full comanche
version
danny rowling said what's your favorite
predator kill in this film man man
there's so many they're all kind of i
mean the bear fight was like pretty cool
too yeah i don't want to like really
want to spoil any of the stuff i wasn't
looking at it at that way
i was just i was just trying to see the
movie in its entirety and then usually i
watch the you know predator films
several times so
you know
multiple viewings you pick up a lot more
i'd say the dude with the pistol how he
died
that was pretty [ __ ] up
yeah
i mean he was kind of a jerk but he was
he was the least jerkish
other friendship remember he tried to
help her yeah well that's what i'm
saying that's why i'm saying she was in
the cage
wasn't he the guy yeah he was like the
only nice guy yeah i think that was the
same guy where he's like or should we
really be doing this i mean yeah he was
like maybe she let her you know i think
i think
i was on the impression he wanted her
out of that cage yeah well they were
thinking about i mean they weren't sure
what was happening well they captured
her and they captured her brother toby
and they were pretty much like because
and i like that they actually added that
historical thing because the french fur
trappers and the comanche were uh
really not friends like around this time
period uh so that was very period
accurate like the kind of war the
conflict between the two of them so i
thought that was kind of a nice touch
that there was a long period in american
history called the french and indian
wars
and ameri and early american colonists
were involved in it too
it was the french and their indian
allies and the american colonists and
their indian allies fighting each other
over fur trade that
george washington was involved in that
too that went on for a long time
so they're kind of talking about that
that era probably a little bit pre that
era what year is it supposed to be 17
19. okay yeah so
that's it's it's pre that era
by the 1760s
i think you're dealing with
1750s then washington is involved in
that
yeah but it was uh it was a rough time
fur was big money they were selling that
[ __ ] back in europe it was like better
than gold
yeah i mean yeah it was they were making
hats and everything out of it
tammy says look what the french did to
all the bison yeah they did find out
because they thought originally that the
monster did it but yeah they found out
that birch did that like [ __ ] [ __ ]
uh john smith said i like to think the
predator in this movie is a young
unblooded hunter that's why it's here on
earth fighting mild threats like humans
that's why it has lesser equipment yeah
see you could totally like
you could totally like that totally
makes sense
that totally makes sense too but like i
said id
yeah
you you know you talk about hundreds of
years before
predator one yeah
so the rules would have been different
yeah and uh yeah we don't know how their
symbolization
the culture would have been different
for them and they would have been using
different things and there would have
been different rules
they were definitely using what they
would consider primitive weapons though
which we do that today i'm [ __ ] fully
qualified for primitive weapon hunting
and you know [ __ ] i grew up with it
i'll show you my bow all right but it's
just
that's what he's doing that's not modern
weapons from his point of view they're
space faring
okay darts are not [ __ ] modern
weapons that's primitive
some of the stuff that he had looked
like it was made out of bone
that helmet and everything but it had
laser beams in it laser trackers in
there so it's a mixture of stuff that
he's using
but like i said this isn't warfare this
isn't murder this is sport hunting
so it's supposed to be difficult
and a challenge yeah
so it's not efficient yeah by design
it's not efficient so i mean they go to
earth and they're like well what is the
overarching like what weapons do my
adversaries have
and it's just kind of like i'm gonna use
an equivalent thing with maybe like
slightly something yeah a little bit oh
[ __ ] i transferred all my i was gonna
show you a picture of me with a dead
deer that i hunted at 16 years old and i
got a muzzleloader
you know i could have gone out there
with a machine gun
all right but that's not the point
you know what i mean it's not warfare
against the deer it's sport hunting and
to get food
meat we ate it you know
but so you go there's there's there's
what's called a primitive hunting season
which is at different times
in mississippi primitive primitive hunt
starts earlier
and it's on and it's within a certain
window and during that time you can hop
before everybody else
but it must be a primitive weapon so
it's either a bow or a muzzle loader
that's what he's doing
his primitive season yeah yeah
danny rowling said moral of the story is
never underestimate an opponent
[Laughter]
yeah i mean like i said i really liked
that that was kind of like and like i
said i really liked that the main
character
they didn't make her like super good at
everything from the beginning like for
most of the movie she [ __ ] up and she
like she wasn't a merry suit yeah not
not in the least and i don't i don't
know like i said i didn't watch any of
this stuff beforehand so like the
trailer or anything so i don't know if
that's how they made it look but
she absolutely was not like that she was
like she [ __ ] up a lot of times like
through her first hunt like she [ __ ]
it all up she had to be carried home by
her brother
she didn't do it and so i like that they
kind of and like i said she ends up
using
what she's good at like her skills and
tracking and things like that rather
than
physical strength so it's not like she's
like oh i'm this tiny girl that's like
fighting this big monster and uh she
survives partially an element of luck
that's it yeah which would be the same
with uh arnold schwarzenegger partially
luck
like that was luck
that that alien was standing underneath
that counterweight
and [ __ ] well that's what i'm saying
and i think that a lot of people forget
that the kind of point of the first
movie right was that yeah all these
dudes were like big and buff and strong
and they had machine guns and [ __ ] like
that but they were still getting their
asses kicked yeah so it didn't really
matter yeah like it was all like
you know who was the best like
strategist like strategically you kind
of and luck
it didn't really necessarily have to do
with who had the biggest guns or had the
biggest muscles or anything like that it
didn't really come down to that but
predator one
the moral of the story is there's always
a bigger fish
yeah they kept showing bigger dudes and
bigger dudes and bigger dudes and all of
a sudden an alien and he was a bigger
dude and he was wiping them all there's
always a bigger fish yeah and in the end
arnie
the arnie character dutch
he um
does go primitive yeah exactly he does
try to outsmart it he makes a trap but
the trap fails but by luck
the alien
stood underneath the damn counterweight
and he went wait a minute hold on and
[ __ ] just sprung the trap and the
counterweight crushed it
that's what i mean
and you don't have to be like a big buff
dude to do that right that's the point
that i made but in that particular case
arnie survived along that time because
he did have physical endurance right a
lot of dudes would have gotten tired and
[ __ ] it so it did help it did happen
right i'm not saying it doesn't help i'm
just saying that it doesn't necessarily
mean that you won't get your ass handed
to you by like a hunter alien in in in
in the final few seconds it was more
like quick thinking yeah it was like oh
[ __ ] hey it went around the trap but
guess what it's standing underneath the
counterweight he [ __ ] kicked it
yeah and then he kind of had mercy he
almost didn't want to kill it
but then it destroyed itself
he had to run it was it's a good story a
classic story
danny rowling said tom break out the
sexual tyrannosaurus hat for this oh
that's in the other room
i can't believe you didn't wear the
sexual for crazy she should have put a
[ __ ] actually you should have thought
straight up dinosaur i mean you straight
up [ __ ] erectile dinosaur
yes actually yeah yeah like i said
eventually somebody's gonna make a
predator versus dinosaurs maybe
all right so you want to shut it down uh
and get us some uh get something to eat
yeah i'm getting pretty hungry all right
so tomorrow is our big regular
livestream episode yep and the topic
that won this should actually be an
entertaining show is
frogging if you don't know what that is
that's people that secretly are living
in your house and you don't know and you
don't know about it yeah imagine it uh
much like the hider in the house thing
on lifetime
so
there's been situations where somebody's
hidden in somebody else's house for like
years and you didn't know the
[ __ ] was hiding your house and
eating out of your refrigerator
using your showers
the pitch didn't even flush what the
hell but yeah so we're going to talk
about that like we'll talk about some
cases of that so that should be a fun
show so remember to drop by uh tomorrow
evening at 6 pm eastern standard time
and we will see you guys again tomorrow
bye